une exposition pour éclairer sa lanterne
le musée de la ville de Saint-Quentin en
Yveline propose les allumés du design ce
voyage à travers le temps des années 60
à 80 met en lumière les luminaires
lampes articulées spot ou suspension
décorative ces appareil électrique
occupe aujourd'hui une place centrale
dans notre quotidien et durant les
années pop un foisonnement d'inventivité
des créateurs avec une une une grande
remise en cause du luminaire
traditionnel l'invention de de for
nouvelle et pour aller jusqu'à des
parfois des luminaires qui ressemblent à
tout sauf à des luminaires puisqu'on est
aussi dans dans une période un petit peu
antionformiste et on aime bien détruire
les les styles ou les genres des
générations précédentes depuis 1879 et
la conception de l'ampoule à
incandescence ces objets ont connu de
nombreuses évolutions avant tout
consacrés à la fonction d'éclairage la
lampe crée des ambiances lumineuses dans
les foyers dès les années 60 c'est aussi
un peu un âge d'or de la vie familiale
de la vie sociale on reçoit
beaucoup et donc l'intérieur euh on y
accorde une place très très importante
on on le soigne création de formes
particulière grâce à l'arrivée du
plastique fais au sculpé avec l'ampoule
halogène les progrès technologique ont
permis une plus grande audace artistique
comme avec ses luminaires conçus par des
créateurs italiens ces pill sont en fait
des des pilules géantes qui qui
deviennent des des lampes donc c'est euh
aussi des des une esthétique qui qui
s'inscrit dans ce qu'on appelle
l'antiign d'inspiration pop art ou
minimaliste environ 80 lampes présentent
l'émergence du design contemporain au
musée de la ville de Saint-Quentin en
Yveline des idées lumineuses à retrouver
jusqu'au 24 février 2024